on this episode Arianna Huffington stops
by
you ask
my
this is
ask Gary B
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 213 of the askgaryvee
show there are a lot of people excited
about this episode a lot of chatter on
the slack channel for you my dear please
tell the vaynernation for the four
people that are watching this that don't
know who you are please tell them who
you are
hi vaynernation i'm so excited to be
here I'm Arianna Huffington as you can
hear from my accent I was not born in
this country and I'm an immigrant a
naturalized immigrant whatever that may
mean
bottom line last chance to be deported
if there is a trump presidency the more
chance to be deported just because of
the stances I have taken against him I
was born in Greece I have two daughters
I have written 15 books and I have
excuse me you just say 15 jeez I was
proud of my 4 that's a real number I got
a lot of work good job I'm gonna go
hustle see ya and together with Kenny
Larry with a good job of Gary's I
launched the Huffington Post in 2005 so
we are now 11 years old and we want what
a run that was amazing you know before
we get into questions I'm curious my own
self what when you when you guys
launched that it you know it didn't feel
like yes like you know did you not know
did it get much bigger than you thought
is it is it still not as big as you
thought like what was your real point of
view well we we were very excited about
taking the conversation that was going
on among really interesting people some
known some not known and moving it
online believe it or not 2005 bloggers
were still dismissed as people who
couldn't get a job writing in their
parents basement yes and we change the
paradigm because like on our first day
we had Larry David and Ellen DeGeneres
and Walter Cronkite and Arthur
Schlessinger you know people who could
have written an op-ed in the New York
Times that's right but chose to write on
HuffPost and discovered
much easier it was to actually write
something online see it immediately
posted not having to deal with editors
and editing and it just began to change
the perception around blogging and at
the same time that we very proudly we're
a platform that is grown of course
exponentially we wanted to be a
journalistic enterprise that ended up
winning a Pulitzer we now have over 800
journalists reporters editors in 15
countries soon 16 so you know whenever
you start something I don't know if you
ever really know what it's going to go
because the fun of it is that you invent
it as you go along but you've been
tuitions yeah you have intuitions you
trust that this is for me it's all about
are you tapping into something in the
zeitgeist I think that's right if you
tap into something you have the wind on
your back and it's much easier this is
the sleep platform the sleep revolution
the book that came out like it was that
typing into the zeitgeist was that a
passion like where did this come from
so will it definitely stopping to the
side guys but it came from a terrible
wake-up call when I collapsed from sleep
deprivation and burnout and hit my head
on the way down on my desk broke my
cheekbone and that was the beginning of
my but literally coming to in a pool of
blood and having to ask myself is this
really what success looks like and
realizing that not just a high but
millions of people have bought into this
color how much how much were you
sleeping at that point I was sleeping
like four to five hours I was you know
yes and building the huffington post you
know it was two years old and I had two
teenage daughters and officials in 2007
2007 years and the precipitating
circumstances my collapse was having
been around colleges with my daughter
for her to decide what college she
wanted to and to go to and what happened
is that we're basically together during
the day know blah
queries that was the ground rule and
then at night she would go to sleep I
will start working and I feel there's
been such a with so much misinformation
about sleep you know going back to the
Industrial Revolution when we started
thinking human beings can be treated
like machines to minimize downtime I
think I'm a machine you are a machine
but but and people know I work a lot
I'm I and I say this a lot I'm a huge
believer in sleep like I always talk
about hustling 18 hours a day and you
know and throwing those kind of crazy
numbers out but boy I'm like all in on
sleep like it's just math in the same
way like I start taking care of my
health a couple years ago like you need
to sleep like I don't think anybody's
won the game of like for example most
people think I think I'm really curious
I think a lot of people in a guard 4 to
5 from you a lot of them like oh that's
what Gary sleeps I'm rarely five mainly
six sometimes seven it's when I travel I
can get caught but I'm sleeping like I'm
a much bigger fan of sleep I think than
people realize and you know now it's you
it's athletes a lot of athletes are
talking about how when they get enough
sleep it makes them better on the court
or in the field like I had a whole
section here
Andre Iguodala and how when he went to
eight hours sleep yes
he stands dramatically improved the
LeBron James Roger Federer when he plays
Wimbledon he rents two houses one for
his wife and young children and one for
himself because he says nothing can
disturb my sleep denied the night before
game day so people may wonder how much
sleep do they need so here's the thing
you may have a genetic mutation if you
have a genetic mutation you can get away
with four to six hours frankly the rest
of us the vast majority of us need seven
to nine hours Wow
you know you may be seven you may be
nine you make response time he looks
fabulous so
maybe that's what is eggs alright India
let's cook look I'm by podría let's get
into some questions and we'll keep
jamming Oh a video I love it
all are they're all video except one
okay great hey Ariana carry me carry on
it was so bad to eat last week we had
our sold of American girl last night to
600 people of the Paris theater not home
at 4 o'clock low Committee now heading
to brush with my parents as its
Bloomberg for an interview so my
question for you
we have so much to go on you're on the
go
how do you recommend we rest during this
really intense couple of weeks
and sometimes months but we can't
full eight hours of
thank you so much well first of all if
something happens and you are shipping a
product or about to get something
moments in time moments in time yes this
is a moment in time and you didn't get
your full night's sleep try and get
twenty minutes of a nap as soon as you
can during the next day it will make you
more productive the rest of the time it
resets your whole system is that okay I
apologize is that a general thing
because for me I'll tell you boy if I
took a 20 like it's I'm a momentum guy I
was think about the mutation thing I'm
like oh I wonder if I'm a mutation might
be you can check yourself I can yeah you
can't have a test there's a genetic test
I'm going to do that and the reason I
said that is boy I'm so momentum that if
I was to take and I know and I've heard
about the naps and like pods and offices
and I'm fascinated by this I'm like ooh
that it's even tough for me to have a
meal in the middle of day because for me
to get Starla I can start but to take a
20-minute nap I it's so difficult ache
naps I have a lot of natural energy I
get all that is it is that back to your
thing that the mutations but for most
people that will work like can most
people take naps absolutely let me look
at Winston Churchill I mean we're
talking about regular naps in the middle
of fighting the Second World War right
in a banker who had a way to take a nap
yes Charlie Rose who has his morning
show his regular interview show he takes
three naps a day for how long you know
just 20 minutes each so what are you so
have you started doing the left I don't
I don't do naps because I get enough
sleep no I now get eight hours 95% of
the time is that right either what about
with the travel but you're doing a
Dallas tomorrow okay so here's the thing
you I can make sure that you get enough
sleep even when you travel you need a
transition to sleep that's the key okay
this is the most important thing I'm
going to say other than the fact that
the science is in on sleep right we're
not debating something right this is not
subjective it's not subjected this is
not some Greek immigrant woman right
crazy idea you're not from America get
out
this crap yeah I was born in Belarus
Bella laughs I know but you have no
accent which makes me feel bad like in
when I was three it makes me feel I'm
tone-deaf oh yeah so go ahead but anyway
beyond the fifty pages of scientific
endnotes the most important I'm going to
say is that we need a transition to
sleep if anybody who is watching his
children you know that you don't just
drop your baby and your young child to
bed
you give it a bath you put it in its PJs
you sing it a lullaby do you think the
modern parents are doing way too much of
that transition I do some of these
things have become four hours long I
have four hours
you sound like Chelsea Handler modern
men and women have dropped the
transition the transition is you're
texting emailing you put your phone by
your bed you turn off the light and then
what happens is that you may be
exhausted enough to go to sleep but your
brain has not been given an opportunity
to wind down so it's going to wake you
up in the middle of the night with all
this in a charter that is completely and
utterly unproductive is it possible that
I'm a mutant because I can literally
even though I'm one second ago complete
and insanity in my brain that if I turn
on my sound machine will go to sleep
immediately have I trained my body and
you're going to sleep and you're gonna
wake up that's right look at milk you
could literally come into my house punch
me in the face and I will not wake up
that means you're way too exhausted got
it you know what I'm saying I would make
a lot of sense
it literally yes it means that you
remind me of me but you're a collab I
don't want to wake up in a pool of blood
let me tell you what would happen to me
I would literally my friends would joke
that they would go to a movie house
before they before the movie started I
would be asleep they would put me in a
car I would be asleep like our so
sleep-deprived that the minute it was in
any darkened place or I didn't have to
function I would fall asleep yes I don't
do that I've never fought I've actually
never fall inside of you tent okay Ken
oh my god like we're already just myself
and honestly by the way I'm getting a
lot more seven and six seven and eight
then anybody would imagine and on
weekends I'll go 11 I think sleep is now
we're getting the truth okay
you actually give yourself a lot of
recovery what I'm doing is Monday
through Friday no question that game can
be six and you know and and seven and
when I play basketball it could be even
a little earlier because we have a six
a.m. tipoff set they get up at 5:30 but
but I almost consistently will try to
make up time Friday night to Saturday
Saturday night to Sunday Sunday like I
just don't know like it's just I'm a big
believer that's all but now I'm not
worried about what people how much sleep
they get I'm worried about what they do
while they're awake okay but the two
things are connected because if you wake
up fully recharged it means you wake up
ready to take on the world you know that
feeling you wake up and you say come on
bring it on it doesn't matter how many
obstacles challenges setbacks said I
prefer those things okay
perfect well you know Travis is a friend
of yours I just joined the board of uber
services a little bit of that like he
may be dealing with 30 crises at the
same time he eats a for lunch but what
happens and here's the kid who just put
something on your Facebook guesser that
I love which is it sound completely just
business that's it it's not life and
death that's right
the people who have a hard time are the
people who basically make it too
important its respective is everything
and that's really what stoic
philosophers believe do you know with my
greatest here rather than yogurt yes
I'll pick I'll pick a dead person his
Marcus Aurelius I'll tell you why he was
the emperor of Rome pretty big job
you're green like right in the arena
dealing with invasions plagues
everything and he was also a stoic
philosopher and literally nothing ever
guarded him he wrote a book about it
called meditations that I have by my bed
and every time I'm beginning to get
anxious about something or worried or I
look at that book and the fact is if you
considered life as though everything
that happened was a hidden blessing I
agree with that I don't know why I don't
know how but another favorite of mine
Rumi you know the Persian poet he said
live life as though everything is rigged
in your favor
I think optimism is the
my drug and we don't know we don't
really know enough about what's
happening in life so whatever happens I
mean for me some of my biggest
heartbreaks led to my biggest moments of
joy and happiness and success India love
that love that I believe in that stuff
so much doctor doctor hi Arianna hi Gary
I'm coming to you from my dental office
in North Bergen New Jersey and my
question is in regards to sleep how do
you develop rituals for sleep and
bedtime when your life is unpredictable
as a business person and a parent and
you have a lot of obligations and a lot
of people contacting you at all hours of
the day
thank you okay well first of all you
know what I tell you and aeroplanes put
your own oxygen mask first you got is
key you know they don't say that because
they are nice they say that because you
won't be much use to anybody else if you
are not breathing so you're not going to
be much used to your children your
patients anybody if you let yourself
burn out so nobody should be able to
reach you at all hours unless you have
what I have which is a dumb phone that
has no data for my daughters and for our
overnight news editor if there is a
crisis but my regular phone that a lot
of people have that has all my life and
my work on when I'm asleep
it is asleep and it is outside my
bedroom same thing for me I haven't by
my bed but it is completely on silent it
is it never wakes me up I never know I'm
out like I totally agree with that and I
think I think it's binary it like to
answer your question after either you
are doing this or you're not there's no
half pregnant in these strategies you
know so for me with health two years ago
I went all in and so now I found the
hour that I didn't think existed I think
she needs two hours cuz you gotta get
ready shower after like it's just binary
like if you want to if you believe it if
you read this book if you believe this
thesis if you google if you watch her
interviews if you believe in this if
this has been bubbling up now if you
have a job where you have to get paged
and come in firefight or doctor like
that's just
doesn't happen every night no it does
even even if you're a doctor how many
times do I wanted to ask you how many
times is the news editor yeah it hasn't
happened yet now no major thing has
happened yet that won't wash me up and
then my and that's what my I haven't
heard from my daughters either it's just
a security blanket yes it means you know
it makes you feel better but but the
point is that it is absolutely critical
to realize it would be living under a
collective delusion I have to say that
you know we are now where we were in the
sixties regarding smoking if you the
science was in but people who are still
glamourizing smoking and they were
doctors I saw an ad the other day from
the sixties of a doctor in a white coat
saying I smoked Mantle's because they
refresh my throat yeah that's where we
are with sleep deprivation yeah you know
it's funny over the last year and a half
probably not often enough and probably
why I had so much passion to do this
with you so I have something to point to
um I've sprinkled in a lot more of
hustle but that means what you're doing
when you're awake not don't sleep don't
watch four hours of horse house of cards
you want to build a business right don't
play video games for six hours but get
your sleep in and this I've been
thinking about more evergreen pieces of
content that I can point to when people
like Gary you don't sleep I'm going to
watch this episode with Arianna like so
that had a lot that was exciting because
people are looking to you and I tend by
the way ice and I sell hard work yeah
and I want to make sure that it's
clarified as in I'm more worried about
playing candy crush for an hour when you
want to build a big business versus
taking that away from you absolutely you
know hard work is not the problem I'm
not talking about slowing down just look
at what I'm getting done I'm talking
about being your most efficient best
self when you show up for work
how much is how much is that young man
sleeping tell him I sleep so damn is my
fabulous chief of staff every single
night eight hours eight hours and we
work hard you know we get it done we
also like crazy but when mmm and before
you how long have you guys been together
a year and a half and so before that for
that I
honestly thought that the hustle masks
giving up wellness and sleep right and
she was convinced that because because I
hadn't drunk yet kool-aid event so it's
a collective dilution and so what were
you spending sleeping Oh maybe you've
five hours yes maybe because I wanted to
be and I want to brag about I'm gonna
say hey folks yeah I don't sleep in
there but I am working my heart yeah
it's funny
snapchat has been interesting like like
to me I guess last night but not last
night man when I don't six to me is the
number I'm really like if I'm under six
I'm very concerned and I'm usually I'm
under six and you guys know this you
follow me on snapchat is when I travel
but then I sleep on the flight you know
to make sure I close that gap right and
then you know when you check into a
hotel especially after a flight I highly
recommend a hot bath a hot shower
there's something wonderful about water
like washing away a big fan and they
gave you getting to do right
remember those 10 seconds you were an
assistant yeah when I was like showering
before I go I'm a big fan you get in the
shower yeah I I read I buy hotel rooms
from the night before because there's no
early check-in absolutely essential that
there's no better investment than
investment in yourself don't buy a bag
buy a hotel room there how you going to
show up the next morning that's the key
India one more one more favor first
anonymous question ever someone what
didn't want to be had their name on it
this is the perv is the first it's a
very big moment anonymous wants to know
how do you deal with bullying in the
workplace or in life uh bullying in the
workplace I mean if you're an adult this
should be absolutely not allowed I mean
leave apply to HR you know just create a
stink you know that's your not five
right if you have a job you are
responsible for what's happening in your
environment and what you allow one of my
sayings is you allow promote or create
everything that happens to you so if you
put up with bullying that's just
completely unacceptable and thank you
for asking the question I hope you just
take action immediately
I you know I'm in the same energy and
I'll say this the fear of whatever
you're going to miss out on I'm not
being at that job whether it's the pay
scale you love doing the work what I'm
not fear is of what you're leaving
because leave is the answer I mean you
can go to HR I mean you know I'm cynical
to it I mean it's I think we have an
incredible that's why we have a cheap
hard officer like I'm passionate about
this but I'm realistic enough to know
that a lot of corporations HR is
underwhelming
so yes clearly but I'm going to make
that assumption that you've gone down
that route if not that would make sense
to go down that route but number two you
need to understand that whatever you
think you're leaving that fear there are
seven twelve fifteen other versions out
there your psyche is not allowed in you
to get there but it's just true and if
you had enough courage and want the need
to email us to have this question asked
you're already on third base there's a
lot of people that are still sitting it
within her head and don't have the
courage to reach out to India to get it
on the show the fact that we decided to
put it on like I'm hoping this moment
becomes the catalyst for you to actually
realize and first of all if it's money
if it is by the way like you make a
hundred thousand and you think you can
only get 85 I promise you the money
isn't worth the mental struggle you're
going through it because because look
what's going on the world first we've
got into the physical right the health
the weight the exercise you're going
here I think mental health is a
conversation that is going to explode
over the next decade to to and so you
know there's no dollar amount worth it
and you could say easy for you guys
you've done well I've got college loans
that's fine
but when you're broken down mentally you
have absolutely no chance of succeeding
whatsoever that's it you know when I
agree what you said about mental health
yes because I feel that what's happening
in college is now with the epidemic of
binge drinking drugs depression anxiety
I have a whole section here about how if
you scratch
sleep deprivation in 80% of cases and
you find that depression and anxiety
they're very interconnected sure you
know it's like anecdotally we know when
we are exhausted we see the world in a
away you know we're cranky rahmani-r is
the boss and I think it's so fulfilling
I actually think I sleep so well because
I'm at peace I'm not kidding
I'm just happy and so it's easy for me
to go to sleep I'm not thinking about
bad things you're not thinking about bad
things it's easy to go to sleep like
most people are staying up you're not
Muslim you're not staying up thinking
about awesome stuff
yes you're worried and so we can get a
mental piece like that I really believe
that that's why I sleep so well because
like it's good now that is key but
that's it's a vicious cycle it's like
when you are sleep-deprived you're more
likely to be worried and anxious and
when you're at peace you are more likely
to go to sleep or enter the guest always
gets to ask the question of the day we
do a question of the day where you get
to ask the entire vaynernation anything
you want they leave lots of hundreds and
hundreds of answers in YouTube and
Facebook that you guys could look at and
get some insight you can go anywhere
with this very entrepreneurial kind of
crowd a lot of different demos and ages
as you saw by the videos what do you
want to ask so I want to ask Boehner
nation when was it that you started
thinking that sleep depravation burnout
where the way to succeed and was there a
moment when you walk up to the fact that
that's not the truth I love it thanks
for coming on thank you so much real to
have you thank you you keep asking
questions we'll keep answering them
what's up guys hope you enjoyed the show
please do I get to link it up anywhere
is it like in here or is it down boo is
it in print or is it in my video yeah
it's here down to my left
like right here there's a button for
them to subscribe to my YouTube video
yeah it's a little buggy thing that's
right guys click this that's right use
that